Cheap
cheap
stuff.
[Silence]
If we could please keep the
noise down to a minimum.
We have a big, beautiful,
fantastic, shiny gym right across the
hallway.
You can run in it and scream in it until
you turn blue in the face.
We'd ask everyone cordially,
all the children
to the gym, please.
If you want to continue to play
upstairs, the running, the pounding
is very loud down here.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
It is extremely loud up there.
Starting tonight inshallah with surah
noon. It's called surah no. It's also
referred to as surah due to the first
verse
and the second verse the first verse
and the second verse. And this is often
where chapters get their titles from.
The chapters of the Quran
most usually
have their names derived from
one of two places. Number one, the
opening verses. If those opening verses
are unique to that chapter or two,
something unique, a topic that is unique
that is mentioned in that chapter that
is not mentioned elsewhere. So for
instance,
it's referred to as anab because this
animal and its name is not mentioned
anywhere else. So it is identified by
this name.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam named
most of the chapters.
The companions of used to refer to the
chapters
by various names.
And so some of them we have chains of
narration going directly back to the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam with
respect to the name of the chapter.
whilst others are known amongst the
companions and the scholars of the Quran
and are referred to and they are most
usually referred to in this way for
instance
it's referred to as
the prophet sallallahu alaii wasallam
referred to it as
why because that's the only chapter
that begins with and has a sag in it.
No is very similar. This is the only
chapter in the Quran that begins with
the singular letter noon.
It's also one of the only chapters that
opens
or the only chapter that opens with the
mention of the pen.
And so those are the two very well-known
names of Alam.
This chapter is a mechan chapter as
we've come to know and it is 52
verses in total
and it is often cited
as
the fourth chapter to be revealed to the
prophet sallall.aii.
Now remember, we've mentioned this many
times before and that is that just
because a chapter is revealed or the
scholars for instance mentioned that a
chapter is revealed in this order
doesn't necessarily mean that every
single verse in that chapter was
revealed at the same time. Some chapters
have other chapters that were
revealed
throughout
or even some chapters took years to
complete.
for instance, what is cited most
usually by the majority of the scholars
as being the first chapter revealed to
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam in
Medina.
Who knows this? The first chapter
revealed in Medina. Yes. Al is the first
chapter in Mecca. That's the first
chapter. We want the first chapter in
Medina.
Alakurah
Bakar is usually referred to as the
first chapter revealed in Medina. Other
site surah.
Now what is the last verse that was
revealed to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam?
[Silence]
And this is part of which chapter?
So we know that this chapter took 10
years to reveal and there were many
other chapters that were revealed
throughout
many other chapters, right? And so when
the scholars mention this chapter was
revealed first, second, third, fourth,
it doesn't necessarily mean that all of
it was revealed at once. And most
usually it's not the case.
Many many many chapters are revealed
intermittently and they're revealed
simultaneously along with other chapters
at the same time.
Surah noon. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
begins this chapter with noon. This one
letter one letter noon. And this is
one of 20some chapters of the Quran
that begin with letters.
That's the way that the chapter begins.
It begins with letters.
Very interesting things come to light
when we take all of these letters and
try to study them individually and
together. First of all,
there are 28 letters in the Arabic
alphabet. Exactly 14 of them are
mentioned,
half of the Arabic alphabet is mentioned
in these opening letters, chapters that
are opened with these letters.
etc. There are many chapters that open
in this way. When we take all those
chapters, take all those letters without
repetition, we find that it is exactly
half of the Arabic alphabet.
And these are the most unique and most
necessary letters of the Arabic
alphabet. The most unique and most
alphabet.
We also notice a pattern that any
chapter that is begun with a letter or a
series of letters, those letters are the
main
ingredient used to compose that chapter.
So for instance,
If we were to take every letter and give
it a tally, how many times is it used in
this chapter? We'll find that the ch
that the letter that is used the most in
is going to be which letter.
If we were to look into Bakar, it begins
with al if lamb.
If we were to look which letter is used
the most in Bakar, it will be al and
then right after
and then right after
in numbers. If we were to look at surah
Mariam and we were to examine which
letters are used the most in surah
mariam number one is going to be ke
number two is going to be number three
is going to be number three etc. kef
yeah so yeah
etc. We we get the point here. The
pattern this pattern becomes
becomes obvious when we look at
something with respect to the numbers,
the number of times that this letter is
used. But that's very great. That's
nice. That's unique and interesting and
all of that. But what does it mean? What
does it really mean? That's really the
point. What are we to understand?
Is there any part of the Quran?
Now, think really good before you
answer. Is there any word or any part or
sentence or verse of the Quran
that the ummah of Islam as a whole does
not know the meaning of?
I'll repeat the question. Is there any
verse or part of the Quran
that the ummah as a whole, maybe not
individuals but as a whole
that the of Islam does not know the
meaning of which means they recite it.
They have no idea what it means.
[Arabic recitation]
This would mean that we have an entire
nation that are reciting things that
they don't know what it means. What is
the point of a verse that we don't
understand its meaning? Why? Why do we
have it then?
And so this is a very important point to
reflect on. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us that the reason he revealed the
reason,
excuse me, the reason that he revealed
the Quran is for what purpose?
So that people would reflect on its
verses, on its meanings. Now is
is
are those part of what Allah intended
for us to reflect on? Yes, they are all
part of what Allah intended for us to
reflect on. There is no part of the
Quran that was not intended for us to
reflect on.
The ummah as a whole at every given time
knows the entire meaning of the Quran.
Does that mean that it know that every
person or does that mean that every tiny
secret or nuance is is obvious? No,
that's not what that means. There are
nuances, things that are salt
in the food. It's not what nourishes the
body. It is something which is
something which is novel
nuances
not critical to its fundamental
meanings. Yes, that the will continue
to discover until Allah takes the Quran
back. However, there is no verse of the
Quran which is not known to the ummah.
As a matter of fact, as a matter of
principle,
the first
we say they mean in the first principle
of
when we speak about the hermeneutics of
the science of exigesis.
What is the first principle? The first
principle of
[Silence]
This is an important principle.
This is the first principle and
misunderstanding this will bring about a
lot of chaos with respect to the the
book of Allah.
The first principle is that our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was not taken back
by Allah until he had conveyed and
explained all of the Quran. Every single
verse.
every verse.
Person may say, "Well, hang on a second.
Every verse.
If we were to take every authentic
narration, as a matter of fact, even
weak narrations, we were to take all of
them and compile them together,
would we have a narration of his words
for every single verse of the Quran
that he sat down and said, "This verse
means this. This verse means this. The
answer is no. Why not?
Because the Quran in its is innately
understandable to the Arabs. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala referred to the
Quran as
meaning that it is clear in itself and
clarifies everything else.
Allah also described the Quran as
with a very clear
Arabic language that is the Quran.
And so the default of the Quran is
that it is understood as it is recited.
There are parts of it that could be
misunderstood.
When those parts come up and are under
in and are under threat of being
misunderstood, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam explains it. And that's why we
find that
most of the verses of the Quran did
not need him to sit down and explain it
we do now. Why do we do this now?
This issue of tapsi. Why do the books of
Tia keep getting bigger? The answer is
because there is a thousand
100 1,00 almost 1,500
years
between us and when the Quran was
revealed. How much has changed in the
Arabic language since then? He the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
his companions compared to our time and
what we know to be normal versus
abnormal. We might as well be from a
different planet. Things have changed so
much. So much. Even our bodies have
changed. Even our sizes have changed.
Everything has changed. Our tongue has
changed.
And so for this reason, the scholars are
always commissioned by Allah and
dispatched by Allah and raised up
amongst every generation to make sure
that the Quran is always has a bridge
between the people and the Quran to be
able to access its meanings at any given
time.
And so this is the main function of the
scholars of
however the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
had two main jobs with respect to the
Quran.
Number one he was to convey it right he
was to convey every single verse every
letter of the Quran. That's the first
thing. And the second thing is he was to
ensure that all of the meanings of the
Quran were explained were conveyed as
well. And that is the purpose for his
sending. He was sent to us with the
book. And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala very
often mentions the prophet and the Quran
together.
together, right?
He mentions them together.
Why? Because the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam was sent in order to tell us
and explain to us and ensure that we
understand
the meanings of the Quran.
But the Quran is in Arabic and most of
it is self-evident.
There are aspects of it that need to be
explained and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam did so.
However, every verse of the Quran has
been explained by the prophet
sallall.aii.
its core meaning and what is necessary
for us to know was all explained to him
before he departed from this world.
Now we go back to the letters.
If we were to take the most
comprehensive
Arabic lexicon,
the most comprehensive,
and look up in that dictionary or that
lexicon or that, and we were to look up
the letter non, what does it mean in the
Arabic language, what are we going to
get?
You speak Arabic, spoke it all your
life, right? What does noon mean in
Arabic?
Tell me.
Huh? What does mean mean? In Arabic,
is that a full sentence?
[Arabic recitation]
And that is the point of these letters.
There are a few opinions amongst the
scholars of tied with respect to these
letters. However, the opinion of
starting with the companions Abbas
is that these letters in themselves
don't have a meaning. It's in
English if I were to say ABC. What does
that mean? ABC. Is it a word? No. But it
has a meaning, doesn't it? This is as
easy as ABC. Or we need to go back to
ABC. What does that mean? It's not a
word, right? It's not a sentence, but it
has a meaning.
They don't have a meaning, but they have
an intention. They insinuate something.
We look at
these letters.
Think about where these letters come
from. E comes from down here
all the way at the bottom. This hem,
right? Alif. Alif. Then the next letter
lamb it comes from which part? The
tongue. And then me and that comes from
where? The lips. So now we have three
regions.
Those are the three regions from which
all words in the Arabic language come
from. They come from the throat, the
tongue and the lips. And some letters
come from an amalgamation of more than
one of those two places or three places.
And so every single
chapter of the Quran, six of them, eight
if we count two more,
every one of those eight chapters that
begins with al if lamb mention
in that chapter the beginning, the
middle and the end of humans humanity's
existence every one of those chapters.
So what is the meaning of non noon? We
said it doesn't have a meaning in the
Arabic language. It doesn't. But it has
an what it insinuates.
What is insinuated by noon? What is
insinuated by by
sod what is insinuated is
this book
is comprised of letters that you all
have access to. You all have access to
these letters. There's no new letters
revealed in the Quran. The Quran came
and didn't add any new letters to the
alphabet. You all have access to the
materials from which this Quran is
comprised. However, why can't you make
it?
Why can't you make one? You have access
to the materials.
The letters are there. The words are
there.
However, only Allah is able to use those
to make this Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala when he wishes
to show the miraculous nature of the
Quran if I were to take two people let's
say two s two two masons I want them to
build something for me and I want them
to compete we want to see which one of
them is best or let's say two artists
and I want to I want to see which one of
them is more skilled
in order for that competition to work,
they both have to have access to what?
The same color palette, right? They have
to have both access to the same to the
same paint. If I give one superior paint
and the other inferior, well, it's not
fair then, right? It doesn't exhibit
their raw skill.
So they have to have access to the same
materials in order for the skill or
or mastery or in this case miracle to be
to be put on full display in all of its
splendor. And so Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala the general meaning and tomorrow
inshallah we'll get into the specific
meaning of non but the general meaning
of all of the letters when they're
mentioned this is that
look you claim that Muhammad is the one
who made this Quran up or he and some
other people
all of you unite collaborate You have
access to the same materials. Make one
it. Matter of fact, make 10 10
chapters it. I tell you what, make
one chapter it. Go ahead.
Go ahead.
Here you go. You have these letters. As
a matter of fact, you've had
collectively institutional knowledge of
[Arabic recitation]
alone. sallallahu alaihi wasallam. He's
just one man and he's only 40 years old.
You guys have hundreds of years of poets
and masters of the Arabic language.
People who are literate, people who have
studied other languages come up with a
book that's it, a recitation that's
it, 10 chapters it, one
chapter it.
I'll make it easy for you. three work,
three three sentences. Go ahead, let's
hear.
But they were unable to do so. Right?
And so this is the general intention
behind these
al the general is intention is just like
have you seen a magician a slide
of hand when he tells you okay take a
look at this hat. He's going to pull a
rabbit out of the head. He says, "Take a
look at this hat. Examine it. Is it a
real hat?" He brings an audience member
up. He says, "Is it real? Turn it
around. Any trap doors? Anything
suspicious about this hat?" "No." "Okay,
give me the hat. Look at this rabbit."
That is exhibiting the materials before
they are being used
to do something that the the onlooker
cannot produce. And so this is the
general meaning behind these
what the scholars refer to as
inshallah but then the question comes in
and that is what's the difference
between each of the different chapters
that have different letters. Why didn't
he use al if for all of them? Why noon
here and here and here and why is that?
There is a reason behind that as well.
But generally that's the answer to this
that question specifically we will get
[Arabic recitation]